[Music]
hi this is leo bartolon i'm extension
cropping systems specialist based in
minot
today i'm gonna talk into
how we can build and increase our
resilience into cropping systems
as you may know notice this cropping
season was very tough on north dakota
especially in the north central region
we got extremely drought we under d4 for
a
long long time and the crops were
suffering a lot during this time
if we look at medium term and long term
into the cropping systems there are some
options that we can
take into account
to diminish the problems with the dry
conditions
so one of this is how to increase
organic matter in our in our cropping
systems
so we have an environment that
is very
challenging
to grow crops and to
increase organic matter but with the
right decision into the crop rotation we
can increase the organic matter so one
thing that we should do is increase no
till
so reducing the tillage we can conserve
more water into the soil and then reduce
the evaporation because we can
leave the soil
surface soil surface covered for a long
time
and then we can increase our water
storage
another important thing to do is how we
fit cover crops in our
cropping systems
so it's very challenging
here in north dakota
to
introduce the cover crops especially in
the north central and western part of
the state
but there is a lot of options that we
can rely on to increase
the use of cover crops
especially in the late summer and in the
fall
and then the cover crops can grow
in that period before the frost
and then we have the benefits of living
plants
growing in the short period of time
so these benefits will translate it into
increase over time the soil structure
we need living roots into the soil
to increase soil aggregation
soil structure and then over time not a
short period of time but it takes time
so we can increase our water storage
capacity
so there is a lot of options that have
been researched for north dakota for
grover crops you can look at our
publications
so try to fit the cover crops in your
system
another important thing
that we have saw
this season here in the dry conditions
so
a lot of farmers try to seek moisture
during the planting time
seek moisture i mean
plant deeper than the recommendation
so
we have seen a lot of problems doing
this practice
you know we should plant like two inches
depth and a lot of farmers trying to
plant three inches depth and we saw a
lot of problem for emergency uneven
fields
the soil was crusted
it's a practice that should be avoided
and another issue
that prevents
your cropping systems to be more
resilient
is one thing related to
speed of planting
we came across with several fields with
a
speed planting problem
so it developed the growth in the soil
surface that prevent the proper
emergency of the crops especially
soybeans the most common problem up here
in the region
there is not an easy fix
for building resilience into the
cropping systems
but there is a medium and long term very
feasible options to build your
resilience into cropping systems so
my final message is
try as much as possible to feed cover
crops into your
into your
rotation
scheme
for you get this all this beneficial in
the medium and long term
thank you
[Music]